hello everyone and welcome back to the
third game
of the finals of the opera your rapid we
are in the second day
and as the first game and the first day
ended in a draw now we
have to see who will be victorious on
the second day to claim it all so
uh this is game three like we said the
game one ended by wesley winning a most
impressive game
then game two ended in a draw and now
comes game three and game three is uh
well it's uh it's a spectacular struggle
so i'm sure you're going to enjoy it
uh let's dive straight into it so wesley
again with the white pieces
again goes for e4 uh we have e5 by
magnus knight f3
knight to c6 that's not a knight and the
bishop to c4 we have bishop to c5 by
magnus and
now uh yes now uh now
castles uh just going into the normal uh
normal main line of the joko piano uh we
have knight to f6
and now d3 defending the e4 pawn and the
d6 now
we have c3 making some room for the
bishop also preparing to push the pawn
in the center
and now as you might also play something
like a4 b4 white
black stops that just a5 taking care of
that b4 idea
rook to e1 and now just castles we often
mentioned that here knight g4 going
after the f2 pawn isn't really anything
for black because after rookie two just
h3 pushes away the knight i know i
always mention this but
it it can be useful for uh new players
to you know
not be afraid of ghosts so here we have
castles by magnus and
knight b to d2 just continuing
development bishop back to a7
so the bishop doesn't come under attack
uh at some point white will decide to
push d4
and now knight to f1 shifting the knight
to g3 or e3 depending on what black
plays we have bishop to e6
uh developing the dark square bishop and
the now bishop to b5
here you could capture but that may be
just uh you know playing
into black's hands he gets the semi-open
file for the rook and the very nice
center he can push d5 it will
so nothing uh nothing very impressive
going on here so instead bishop to b5
and now knight to e7 and we actually
reach a position magnus carlsen already
had with the black pieces this year in
the tata still in january
he had it against yang shisht of duda
and that game ended in a draw in that
game
knight to g3 was played by duda but here
wesley plays d4
and it is as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game
so let's see uh how magnus deals with
this new idea
he starts by pushing back the bishop we
have c6 and now
bishop back to d3 and knight the g6 as
planned these knights can now
come to h5 they can come to f4 it's not
going to be
very pleasant for white facing all of
these knights so
h3 making some reading room for the king
also ideas like knights to h2 might be
possible in the future
but just taking away the g4 square from
black's pieces and now
knight to h5 so the one of the knights
is coming to f4
and it's very unlikely that black that
white will be uh interested in giving up
one of the bishops for for that knight
so here bishop to e3
and just knight h2f4 so that night is
now it's not it's not
a monster night as of yet but it is a
very strong knight
so bishop back to c2 uh not allowing
this knight
to to be traded for bishop and the now
queen to c8 and with this queen to c8
move
uh magnus announces that he has some
very nasty plans for wesley's king side
some you know bishop captures on h3 as
an idea
knight captures an h3 is an idea and so
on so here
we have bishop to b3 by wesley uh the
absolutely
most solid is just captures on f4 knight
captures an id3
uh just defending against any bishop
captures and h3 ideas because here
if you go for such a maneuver captures
captures and captures
uh the good thing is that the knight is
covering the g2 square so there
aren't any uh imminent mating threats
available and after knight to h2
white can just bring the queen to g4 and
that's just it black's attack
is not even happening but wesley said
i'm not afraid of any
uh you know uh uh attacks here and he
went bishop to b3
now trying to exchange this bishop for
this bishop and now magnus
needs to decide what to do here so here
uh you
definitely have to go for bishop
captures on h3 that's the whole point of
this um
of this setup but it's not all that easy
to spot because after bishop captures an
h3
g captures we need to play this a4 move
and that's
i mean who who thinks of such a move
because we want to get the bishop away
from this diagonal
white of course will uh prevent this by
playing bishop to c4
then you strike in the center with d5
and then after captures and captures
uh you will also capture on d5 because
now
uh you you do not want to allow after
after black starts grabbing here on h3
that you do not have access to this
diagonal
so here white will in fact play bishop
captures on d5 giving back the piece
now it is the the absolute best move
knight captures on the e5 and now
knight captures an e5 knight captures on
e5d
captures and now knight captures an e3
knight captures and queen capture so
just a massive capture fest here and we
would
get this position where black is
definitely better he has a monster
bishop here
uh beautifully placed queen ended the
rook can definitely
help out by coming into the game so
white would have some difficulties
defending this
so instead after this bishop to b3 move
magnus just played uh
captures on d4 and this is uh not uh the
absolute best way but okay it's fine
i mean you don't calculate all of this
in a rapid game so
knight captures on d4 and now magnus
goes for
bishop captures and e4 again bishop
capture son
b3 is also a possibility here for
example bishop captures and now if queen
captures
this a4 move again happening out of
nowhere
but we just want to get uh the queen
away uh
from the from the king side as much as
possible and also if you capture on a4
uh then you kind of go in front of the
rook here but okay it is possible for
example if queen captures
then we can finally start sacrificing
some pieces knight captures
and now capturing an h3 is impossible
you have to play king h2 or king h1
because if you capture the knight then
just
bishop captures on b4 queen captures on
d4 or bishop captures doesn't really
matter and now this knight to h4
and this knight to h4 is a crucial line
in all of the
sorry a crucial move in all of the lines
that involve magnets actually
sacrificing material
because now we have this problem of
queen captures followed by checkmate and
white is unable to react to this because
just knight to f3 check picks up uh
picks up the queen and if you try
something like king to g2 that's
impossible
because the knight is covering that
square and king h3 also impossible
still runs into the same check winning
the queen so
really really crazy stuff here so after
this knight captures on d4
we have bishop captures on d4 by magnus
and now
c captures on d4 is the only good move
for wesley here however
wesley played queen captures on d4 and
now what did we say
since we know it from the previous line
that we've just seen what is the queen
doing here
on the d4 square well waiting to be
waiting to be forked
in future variations so here feel free
to pause the video and win this game for
magnus while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you that were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh uh just amazing line and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
knight captures and g2 now not on h3
this is very important
because now it doesn't matter what you
play if king captures on g2
then you have this bishop captures on h3
first attacking the king
king to h2 or g1 for that matter
it's all the same if you go h1 then the
queen is coming to g4 and again it's
very scary with the threats of checkmate
and queen to f3
so king h2 and now we have this perfect
setup with the king
on h2 or g1 and the queen on d4 and now
comes again knight to h4 so by
okay we know it from the previous line
but now of course you know the idea the
knight is coming here and there is no
defense against
uh checkmating threats and now if queen
captures on d6 trying to retreat
uh for example with something like this
we just go knight to f3
check king to h1 and bishop captures on
f1
and that's just it the the bishop cannot
be captured because of queen to h3
checkmate
and if you don't capture it then black
will just continue happily grabbing
pieces and it's a winning game
so that's what happens what's happening
after knight captures on g2
uh you could try uh an in-between move
uh a nice fishing suit before actually
accepting the sacrifice with bishop
captures an e6 trying to remove
black's a very strong attacker but then
f captures an e6 and then the rook comes
alive
so here we might see queen captures on
d6 uh just trying to remaneuver the
queen
back to help out with the defense but
then knight captures any one so
it doesn't really help all that much for
example captures and now e5
again you have access to all of these
beautiful squares the knight can come to
h4
and it's going to be impossible for
white to defend this however that's
a lot of possibilities and a lot to
calculate so magnus in fact
did not play this and after queen
captures on d4 magnus actually went for
bishop captures on b3
we have a captures on b3 and now again
the only way to continue
to play for something more than a draw
is to sacrifice here and then to go
knight to h4
uh trying to go for the same line so
white will not be able to capture the
knight so at least you capture a pawn
with
check and you will have a very nice
position if your knight is attacked then
you bring it back
but at least you've you know cracked
open the white's king's defenses
so instead after a captures on b3 magnus
goes for d5 but now
uh now the moment has passed queen to d2
now threatening to win some material
here and only now
magnus captures an h3 but now it's a
little bit different we have g
captures on h3 queen captures and now
f4 with the white queen uh very much
ready to
uh help out with the defense of the king
so knight the h4
now threatening this check to win the
queen and now
knight the h2 and yes uh you could say
okay but
there's this very nice queen captures
here and after queen captures knight f3
check yes
but white black is still uh down
material so after king g2 captures
captures we end this
variation with white being up a piece so
after this knight h2 move we have d
captures on e4 and now queen to f2
now preparing to just defend and
there's not uh all that much black can
do to to continue this attack
so rook f the e8 of course going for
some uh rook lifts and delivering checks
and then now comes queen to f1
offering a queen trade wesley cannot
allow magnus to do this rook lift
queen g3 check and now comes king to h1
and now knight to f5 h5 was also a
possibility here
but you simply don't have the time and
you don't have time for rook to e6
because queen to g1
is coming so here we have knight to f5
uh and now comes queen to g2 offering a
queen trade and magnus must accept this
so captures with check you have to
accept this because if you move the
queen queen g5 and again your queen and
knight are under attack now you you're
gonna have to trade here
so instead after queen g2 we have
capture sanji with
king captures and knight captures on e3
with check
rook captures and now f5 and now wesley
is up a piece
uh but wesley is up uh three pawns so
maybe maybe
sorry magnus is up three points so maybe
if he can start uh those pawns rolling
on the king side maybe maybe good things
can happen
so here knight to f1 uh re-maneuvering
the knight with rook
uh eat the d8 now and now rook ate the
e1
uh sorry uh rook e to e1 just getting
the rook
to the back rank and now preparing to uh
counter uh carlsen's rooks
under d file we have king to f7 and now
rook
e to d1 king to f6 magnus improving the
position of the king as much as possible
and now rook captures we have rook
captures and
rook captures on a1 a5 so wesley grabs a
pawn
here and magnus starts playing on the
king side with
g5 with he of course captures that we
have captures captures
and now king to f2 and now comes h5 so
now
magnus has three pass spawn here past
pawns here two of them being connected
and wesley has to be very careful so he
goes knights to e3
sorry that's a g uh he goes knights to
e3 first
and now b5 uh cutting off the rook from
the defense
from the fifth rank so now he can start
pushing his f pawn
so knights the f1 and now h4
uh and here rook to a7 so he can start
uh some sort of a defense from
uh behind the uh the the kingside pawns
and here the situation on the clock is
wesley is down to two minutes and magnus
has some three minutes on the clock
so rook to h8 preparing to push that
pass pawn
and now rook to f7 rook to f7 with the
idea of trying to bait in
uh this f4 move and the idea is now
he wants to go rook to e7 attack this
pawn and after e3 check create a
blockade with king to f3 and now if you
start pushing the pawn
uh even knight to h2 and now all of the
king side pawns are nicely blockaded and
the white will continue
uh harassing the king and going after
the queen side pawn so here
magnus tries something different magnus
starts h3 right away
and now knight the g3 going after this
pawn and now
if you move it just knight captures here
with check so magnets continues pushing
we have
h2 and now rook captures on f5 we have
kinked the g4
now threatening h1 check knight captures
and the king captures rook
so wesley has to move the rook we have
rook to f6 and now
h1 with queen we have knight captures on
h1
rook captures on h1 and now rook
captures on c6
so now a simple uh king and rook end
game
king to f4 and now rook to f6 with check
king e5 we have rook to f8 and now
rook the h2 with check king to e3
and now rook captures on b2 so now the
the material is equal we have b4
and now rook back to h2 uh we have
rooked the e8 with
check king to d5 and now just rook to d8
with
check if you're wondering why wesley
doesn't grab this pawn well it's because
he doesn't want to blunder the game away
here you would just deliver check
the king has to move away from the
defense of the rook king f4
and now the king can just capture the
rook after this check is given of course
check king moves and just rook captures
so
not possible so wesley just continues
checking carlson's king
rook to d8 check king e5 rook the 88
check and it was in this position that
the players agreed to a draw after this
amazing amazing fight where i mean yeah
it looks very simple to you guys when
you see it like this but there are so
many complications
here and so many variations i just show
you uh the most obvious ones that
are completely forced but you know they
see
so many more moves so many possibilities
and you don't have time to calculate all
of them so
it's very easy to miss uh such uh uh
such a such a clean attack
and one of the reasons uh of course that
uh made
magnus miss this uh whole idea of maybe
uh
sacrificing here on on g2 uh is that he
also sacrificed
yesterday and then wesley uh sorry
sacrificed in the first game and the
wesley
completely obliterated him i didn't even
mean anything that magnus was able to
grab two pawns after sacrificing a piece
so i guess that's why magnus was
reluctant to give up material this game
but
this game you you he had to do it so
yeah
very very impressive stuff very very
nice game excellent defense by wesley
and in the end it ended in a draw so now
it all comes down to the last game the
fourth game where magnus will have the
black pieces
if he cannot win a game uh then wesley
so is the winner of the opera euro rapid
tournament
uh so yeah now that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to thank mr
hoody guy ravi perry
marcus van atten uh philip tuckman and
michelle del monte
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the opera
euro rapid with the fourth game maybe
the final one but maybe not maybe we go
into rapid tie break
into blitz tie breaks so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day